Olha essa notícia aqui que me deixou
realmente impressionado. Uma mulher
passou 26 anos sentindo dores no peito
durante todo o mês, achando que estava
infartando. E sabe o que era?
Endometriose no coração. Pois é, você
não leu errado. No coração. A gente
sempre associa endometriose com cólica
menstrual, com dor pélvica. Mas olha só,
essa doença pode parecer em qualquer
lugar do corpo onde o tecido endometrial
resolve crescer. Eu já vi casos em que
mulheres achavam que tinham herne de
disco, se atalgia, passavam anos fazendo
tratamento pra coluna, tomando remédio
para dor nas costas e no final das
contas era endometriose. O grande
detalhe aqui é perceber o padrão. Se a
dor piora todo mês no período menstrual,
isso é um sinal vermelho aceso que não
pode ser ignorado. O problema é que
muitas vezes demora anos até a pessoa
ter o diagnóstico correto, porque a
endometriose pode se camuflar de outras
doenças.
Então fica o recado. Você tem o dor
cíclica que volta todo mês junto com a
menstruação. Não importa se é no peito,
nas costas ou em qualquer lugar do
corpo. Isso precisa ser investigado a
fundo.